One hundred years before Aegon's Conquest,
Targaryen's ancestral home of the old Valyria
was destroyed,
killing all the dragon lords with only one
of the weaker dragon families, Targaryens,
surviving.
Thanks to Daenys the Dreamer who saw the doom
in her dream
and warned her Lord father to leave before
it's too late, Targaryens survived and came
to Westeros.
This however is a legend and might not be
the true reason why Targaryens left Valyria,
and we will definitely learn about it in the
upcoming Game of Thrones prequel,
either through stories or flashbacks.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, war with Dorne and go all the
way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
Aegon's Conquest is not the first great thing
Targaryens did.
100 years before, they were the only ones
of all the dragonlords to survive the Doom
of Valyria.
It's often referred to simply as "The Doom"
- due to its massive destruction and historical
impact,
most people across the world understand that
this specifically refers to the disaster which
struck Valyria.
The Doom of Valyria, often called the Doom,
was a cataclysm of an unspecified nature that
caused the collapse of the Valyrian Freehold,
which had prospered for five thousand years.
Spells, knowledge, and recorded history were
lost in the Doom,
and the Century of Blood followed the disaster.
For nearly five thousand years, the Valyrian
Freehold had remained the dominant power in
the continent of Essos, thanks to their dragons,
mighty beasts that were a key to their power.
At its height, the Valyrian Freehold ruled
most of Essos - from Pentos to Meereen –
constituting about half of the known world.
However, one fateful day, four hundred years
ago a cataclysm - which became known in later
years simply as "the Doom" - laid waste to
the Valyrian capital, its people, all the
dragons, and the surrounding lands. The string
of volcanoes near Valyria known as the Fourteen
Fires exploded in a massive eruption, consuming
the city of Valyria in ash and flame, and
the entire region was wracked by corresponding
earthquakes. The Valyrian Peninsula itself
was shattered and the ocean came sweeping
in,
becoming the area now known as the Smoking
Sea –
which no sailor dares cross and which is believed
to be haunted by demons.
Twelve years before the Doom, Lord Aenar Targaryen's
maiden daughter, Daenys the Dreamer,
had a powerful prophetic dream along with
visions that Valyria would be destroyed.
Foreseeing the Doom, she convinced her father
to leave Valyria before the cataclysm.
Aenar set sail, moving House Targaryen and
their property and their five dragons to the
island Dragonstone. On the day of the Doom,
every hill for five hundred miles exploded,
filling the air with ash and smoke and fire,
which killed even dragons.
Earthquakes destroyed palaces, temples, and
towns, while lakes boiled or turned to acid.
The Fourteen Flames, the fiery mountains of
Valyria, sent molten rock a thousand feet
into the air,
and red clouds rained down dragonglass.
It destroyed the city of Old Valyria and devastated
most of the surrounding Valyrian Peninsula.
The destruction of its capital city in a single
day, in turn, caused the fall of the entire
Valyrian Freehold, which for thousands of
years had ruled most of Essos.
The proudest city in all the world was gone
in an instant, its fabled empire vanished
in a day.
Valar morghulis was how they said it in Valyria
of old. All men must die.
And the Doom came and proved it true.
The cataclysm fragmented the Valyrian peninsula
surrounding Valyria into numerous smaller
islands
and creating the Smoking Sea between them.
East of Valyria, Velos, and Ghozai on the
Isle of Cedars were destroyed by a tsunami.
The exact cause of the Doom remains unknown:
some believe the volcanic eruption was a natural
disaster, while others believe it was inadvertently
triggered by the Valyrians' own sorcery.
Septon Barth and some maesters believe that
Valyrian spells controlling the Fourteen Flames
faltered. Other explanations include the curse
of Garin the Great, the fire of R'hllor,
or infighting dragonlords assassinating fire
mages.
Whatever the cause, Valyria was destroyed,
and all their dragons were lost with it,
along with Valyrian recorded history, spells,
and knowledge.
With its center of power destroyed, the Freehold
collapsed.
Of the mighty families of dragonlords who
ruled the Freehold, only one survived, House
Targaryen, which had re-established itself
on Dragonstone in Westeros years before the
Doom.
Most importantly, the Targaryens on Dragonstone
possessed the only Valyrian dragons that survived
the Doom, the only remaining dragons in the
known world. As I said in the beginning, according
to legend, Lord Aenar Targaryen abandoned
Valyria with his family
because his daughter Daenys the Dreamer foresaw
the destruction in her dream,
but that might not be the true reason.
As Viserys Targaryen says, it's just as likely
that Aenar met with some mishap at court
and chose exile over execution. Much of Essos
fell into chaos after the Doom.
With the heartland of the Freehold destroyed,
its surviving colonies to the west and east
re-asserted their independence, politically
fracturing the continent and initiating a
series of savage wars for dominance known
as the "Century of Blood",
during which Volantis attempted to reform
the Valyrian empire under their rule.
Several of these colonies formed into the
Free Cities in the west,
and the cities of Slaver's Bay in the east.
Meanwhile, without the Valyrians and their
dragons to keep them in check, the Dothraki
mounted hordes swept across the continent
from the central plains of the Dothraki Sea,
plundering and carving out new domains from
surrounding areas –
from the Dothraki point of view, the Doom
started their own golden age of conquest and
expansion.
In the far northwest of Essos, the hidden
city of Braavos, founded by escaped slaves
who fled Valyria, now revealed itself to the
world. While the other Valyrian colonies were
left in chaos,
Braavos was an island of stability because
it had no political or economic ties with
the Freehold,
and quickly rose to become the most powerful
of the Free Cities.
Some dragonlords in Lys and Tyrosh survived
the Doom,
but they were soon killed along with their
dragons.
The dragonlord Aurion declared himself Emperor
of Valyria
and led a host from Qohor toward Valyria,
but he and his followers were not seen again.
Tommen II Lannister, King of the Rock, vanished
while sailing to Valyria with his blade, Brightroar,
and Gerion Lannister later disappeared while
searching for Brightroar.
It's thus said that no one has returned from
a journey to the ruins of Valyria,
and even the most hardened sailors shudder
at the thought of sailing to ruined Valyria.
Many of Valyria's secrets, such as magic,
the method for creating Valyrian steel,
and ancient records were lost in the Doom.
The disaster is represented in art across
the known world. Songs are sung of the Doom.
Indirectly, the disaster led to the conquest
of the Seven Kingdoms of Westeros by House
Targaryen. In 54 AC during the reign of Jaehaerys
I Targaryen,
Princess Aerea Targaryen disappeared from
Dragonstone with the dragon Balerion.
Balerion returned to King's Landing in 56
AC with a dying Aerea.
Septon Barth, who helped treat her, believed
that Balerion had taken Aerea to Valyria,
its birthplace. Because of her bizarre and
horrific death and the powerful dragon's mysterious
wounds,
King Jaehaerys made traveling to Valyria punishable
by execution,
and prohibited ships that had visited the
area from docking in Westeros.
Let's now listen to what George RR Martin
has to say
about
the Doom.
For
the end, I'd like to read a poem about the
Doom, which in the books,
Tyrion Lannister quoted to Jorah Mormont:
"They held each other close and turned their
backs upon the end.
The hills that split asunder and the black
that ate the skies;
The flames that shot so high and hot that
even dragons burned;
Would never be the final sight that fell upon
their eyes.
A fly upon a wall, the waves the sea wind
whipped and churned —
The city of a thousand years, and all that
men had learned;
The Doom consumed it all alike, and neither
of them turned"
The Doom of Valyira, the true reason Targaryens
left just before it happened,
all of this and more will finally be explained
in the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel,
House of the Dragon, coming in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one.
Peace!